breaking news ladies and gentlemen
insider trading is legal well for
politicians who says so politicians for
the rest of us it's still illegal just
in case you were wondering see our story
today comes from nancy pelosi the queen
the absolute goddess of insider trading
she just made a legendary announcement
today here it is we're gonna listen to
it bear witness to it take a
49 members watch congress and 182 senior
congressional staffers have violated the
stock act um the insider training law
i'm wondering if you have any reaction
to that and secondly should members of
congress and their spouses be banned
from trading individual stocks while
serving congress no i don't know to this
second one um
any uh we have a responsibility to
report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five month
review but if the people aren't
reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
where free market economy they should be
able to participate in that okay it's a
free market that's what she said
should not ban lawmakers from trading
individual stocks so this is absolutely
insane what you're watching is her
getting told that 49 members of congress
have violated something called the stock
act which the whole point of it was to
prevent to stop
insider trading and she says well look
we should just all be allowed to do it
anyways uh
because
freedom now i know if you're an average
viewer you may not fully understand the
scope of what's going on here so we have
to back this up because the corruption
just
it just runs deep honestly guys i don't
even talk about scams of this magnitude
much mostly because it's just political
people get weird about politics but also
because this is a special kind of scam a
legal scam where
the people running the scam also make
the laws so you know it's never going to
be illegal to do what they do and even
if it is you'll never pin them down as
actually committing the crime so to give
you guys some backstory insider trading
is obviously when you know some public
information about a stock and you go
trade based on that information so for
example let's say i have a company in
medicine and i hear about a mysterious
china illness that we may be able to
treat if i know that information ahead
of time and i go out and i buy or sell
stocks based on that material
information i have committed a crime
right if someone from congress from the
government nancy pelosi does the same
thing given that they know non-public
information all the time it is not a
crime they they're they're allowed to do
that um well kind of you see it's a bit
complicated obama signed this law in
2012 the stock act which technically
made it illegal for congress to trade on
insider information for this but the
thing is is that no one's ever been
convicted for this despite lots of calls
of insider trading and the problem is
it's not clear how anyone would ever be
prosecuted for this because of something
called the speech or debate clause which
prevents congress from being questioned
about things they talk about in their
congressional duties or whatever what
this means is if you ever wanted to
convict someone for this you'd have to
question them but you can't question
them because of this rule in fact this
was written about in the challenges of
prosecuting congressional insider
trading it's a law article basically
they're saying look in theory this is
illegal but
there's not much of a way to actually
find this out or pin them down it'd be
like if i was banned from having like
pink shoes in my house or something like
that but i also had a law that said you
could never search my house the question
is is it actually illegal if you can
never prove that i'm breaking the law if
you don't actually have the ability to
ever look into what i'm technically not
supposed to be doing so that's the
conundrum there's a law that they can't
insider trade but there's no way to
prove that they're insider trading
because we can't ask them questions per
this speech or debate clause thing but
of course if that's the case then why do
we have a bunch of reports from places
like insider saying that the
congress and top uh capitol hill staff
have violated the stock act hundreds of
times well the reason is simple because
there's actually multiple parts to the
stock act one of them the only real
thing that actually is going on with the
stock act is that they have to report
what they're investing in at the bare
minimum but they're not even doing that
according to this incredible insider
report on it they've identified 49
members of congress who failed to report
their financial trades and then they go
to list all these people who have failed
to do so and surprise surprise they come
from both sides of the aisle and they're
making a lot of money on the pandemic
ladies and gentlemen trading those tech
stocks trading those pharmaceutical
stocks ladies and gentlemen and this is
what nancy pelosi was asked about and
she basically dodged and said no there's
no problem here it's a free market bro
it's freedom bro but the thing is it's
not freedom this is a problem these
people go to these subcommittees they
have all these special meetings with
google apple they're expected to rule
and
make laws about these companies that
they might have a vested interest in
because they're investing in them or
they're shorting them or longing them
whatever and the thing is is like look
even breaking these laws like this
reporting law what's the penalty for it
well if you break it you know what you
pay a 200 fee that's right the price for
not reporting potential insider trading
as a congress person is 200
but get this even those tiny fines which
is like less than a speeding ticket they
don't even pay that
apparently a lot of people have said
there's no consistent penalty system and
it's not even clear these people have
paid the fines according to insider it's
a situation that ethics experts say
leaves the public in the dark lets
congress off the hook and renders the
stock act which is intended to defend
against insider trading toothless so
that's the real context here there's a
law against instead of trading but it's
useless and the part that's supposed to
work this account reporting you know
what you invested in isn't being
enforced and so many people believe the
solution is to ban lawmakers from being
able to trade single stocks banning
their spouses from being able to do that
because for many of them it's not nancy
pelosi who's investing it's her husband
it's not rand paul who's investing it's
his wife and they just happen to make
killer trades the idea is they'd be able
to trade the s p 500 mutual funds stuff
like that but not be able to trade
individual stocks like normal people
because well they are not normal people
and this just makes sense right like
like if you're going to make laws
investing in google and you know private
information about google you shouldn't
be able to then go and invest in how
it's going to do tomorrow i mean the
level of corruption we're talking about
is so basic so bare minimum it's
absolutely insane and so i and many
people uh kind of support banning this
and that's what nancy pelosi said no to
said no the lawmakers we need access to
those single stocks we got to play the
stock market it's our fundamental right
as insanely rich congress people and
obviously what she's actually defending
here um is her right to get insanely
rich from her insider knowledge like for
example when her husband made a 5
million dollar profit from betting on
google right before congress had an
anti-trust bill i mean was he just lucky
was
that's the ultimate question like you
have to really be
born yesterday to actually fall for the
fact to think that this is an insider
trading you know was rand paul's wife
lucky when she bought shares in gilead
right before the pandemic that's a
pharmaceutical company by the way that
did very well they're the ones who
actually make rim deserve i mean was
that luck was rand paul's wife just the
luckiest investor in the world or was it
a crime right those are actually our two
options are these investors just truly
that good or are they committing crimes
which are technically impossible to
prosecute due to weird speech or debate
laws that are on the books i don't know
i'm gonna leave that up to you and
here's what i want to leave you with as
food for thought this is a graphic
created by
unusualwhales.com who tracks a lot of
these politicians and it ranked the top
20 house members who purchased
securities in 2020 and at the top of the
list
trading the most apparently was nancy
pelosi or her husband at least and it's
worked out quite well for her too since
she's now worth 46 million dollars
despite making only 220 000 a year i
know that sounds like a lot but at her
current salary it would take her 200
years to make as much money as she has
right now and that would be if she never
spent a penny and never paid taxes now
obviously that's not the case she's not
200 years old despite how she looks
where did all this money come from i
mean it's just i don't know i don't know
i guess it's just amazing to see all
these politicians getting so rich just
by being in the free market i don't know
i guess my conclusion is this it's a
scam but it's a legal one i guess for
now so thanks for watching pump the
stock see you tomorrow